[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils sont près de dix mille a transité
chaque jour sur l'axé nord-sud alsacien
et représente près de 20% du trafic de
l'a35
il s'agit des poids lourds si vous avez
déjà emprunté cet axe ce qui est
quasiment certain vous n'aurez pas pu
passer à côté de ces files de camions à
la queue leu leu lui même échappé au
ralentissement provoqué par l'un d'eux
doublant un de ses congénères
tiens tel trafic témoigne en partie de
la vitalité de l'économie alsacienne qui
exportent de nombreuses marchandises
toute l'europe
une partie de ces camions ne marquera
même pas l'arrêt sur le territoire
le passage par l'alsace leur permettant
d'échapper à la fiscalité écologique
mise en place en allemagne de 2005
depuis la mise en place de la motte sur
l'autoroute allemand donc une redevance
sur les autoroutes allemandes
eh bien il ya eu un report de trafic
important de poids lourds en alsace
aujourd'hui la situation n'est plus
tenable
en terme de saturation de la circulation
sur l'axé nord-sud alsacien mais aussi
en termes de santé en termes de fluidité
il faut donc agir et réagir vite
c'est la raison pour laquelle je suis
intervenu auprès de la ministre des
transports mais aussi auprès du ministre
de l'environnement pour trouver une
solution rapide à cette situation la
solution que je préconise et la mise en
place d'une redevance sur la kz2 reçus
deux alsaciens
un projet qui n'est pas sans rappeler
celui de l'écotaxe qui aurait dû être
mise en place sur le tech nationale en
si le projet est tombé à l'eau en 2013
enterré par la contestation des
transporteurs et des bonnets rouges
breton qu il se pourrait bien que la
grèce ait trouvé c'est bonnet vert le
projet d'écotaxe 2014 a été abandonnée
malheureusement par le gouvernement
notamment parce que les bretons s'y sont
opposés or j'estime qu'on ne peut pas
comparer le trafic poids lourds en
bretagne au trafic poids lourds en
alsace nous avons aujourd'hui une
circulation très forte une densité de
poids lourds très forte
dix mille poids lourds par jour sur l'
axe nord-sud
cet énorme demain nous devons mettre en
place une redevance c'est le seul moyen
d'agir de manière rapide et de manière
efficace pour réduire le trafic
l'éco taxe poids lourds un dossier miné
pour tous les gouvernements personne n'a
oublié le fiasco politique et financier
de 2013
pourtant le nouveau ministre de
l'environnement françois de rugy se dit
favorable à la mise en place d'une
vignette poids lourds
ainsi quand les élus alsaciens demande
le droit de mettre en place une
redevance sur notre territoire au
ministère de la transition écologique on
se montre plutôt réceptifs pour
l'instant le retour de l'état que nous
avons c'est que le ministre de
l'environnement propose une vignette
plus lourd c'est la preuve que kylie à
un véritable problème de transit poids
lourds dans notre pays
mais ce que nous demandons chez nous en
alsace c'est que même à titre
expérimental nous puissions dans des
délais rapides mettre en place une
redevance pourquoi une redevance plutôt
qu'une vignette comme le préconise nos
ministres de l'environnement parce
qu'une vignette à mon sens n'est pas
dissuasive
la vignette on la paye une fois pour
toutes pour une certaine durée
et on peut effectuer autant de passages
qu'on souhaite sur l' axe considéré et
donc pour moi une vignette n'est pas
dissuasive
en effet l'objectif de cette redevance
reste principalement de réduire le
trafic en rééquilibrant le coût du
kilomètre des deux côtés du rhin au
conseil départemental
on pointe l'urgence de la situation
alors que l' axe est déjà saturé le
trafic continue d'augmenter nos voisins
allemands s'apprête à étendre leur éco
taxe aux véhicules légers
ce qui n'aura pas non plus pour effet de
désengorger la 35
si les élus départementaux souhaite
inscrire la future redevance dans le
cadre de la nouvelle collectivité
d'alsace une mise en place rapide pour l
avoir géré conjointement par les deux
départements avec des recettes de cette
mouvance qui serait versé le moment venu
à la collectivité alsace mais en
attendant aux deux départements
alsaciens parce que les départements
sont pour compétence les routes et que
donc qui serait normal que nous gérions
également ses routes nationales et les
autoroutes non concédées ses recettes
nous permettrait d'une part d'entretenir
le réseau routier mais aussi d'injecter
de l'argent dans le transport
ferroviaire transfrontalier puisque
c'est une compétence que nous pouvions
obtenir dans le cadre de la collecte qui
tiennent un an
beaucoup d'alsaciens ne serait pas fâché
de voir le trafic poids lourds diminué
sur l'a35 ici peut-être plus qu'ailleurs
on est favorable l'écotaxe reste que les
transporteurs locaux vignette ou
redevance ne voit pas d'un bon oeil
l'apparition d'une nouvelle taxe les
concernant au niveau de l'exécutif
départemental
on tient à rassurer la redevance ne
concernera que les poids lourds en
transit ce qui est important c'est que
la redevance que je préconise avec mes
collègues conseillers départementaux du
haut rhin c'est une redevance qui serait
appliqué aux transporteurs au long cours
aux transporteurs internationaux et nous
prendrons toutes les mesures pour que
les transporteurs de proximité ne soit
pas affectée par cette redevance
il est encore trop tôt pour connaître
les détails de la mise en place du
projet tel que la façon dont seraient
collectées la future redevance le
gouvernement réserve d'ailleurs toujours
sa réponse
mais à l'hôtel du département on est
confiant et l'on part sur une mise en
place prochaine